2020 was my year of being like
letting everything go and just like no
fear sofia richie and scott disick
called it quits in june after
three years together now a source tells
e.t
she's not looking for anything too
serious when it comes to relationships
great things are happening and i'm
really excited about it rumors recently
circulated that the 22 year old model is
dating 27 year old chacha matcha
co-founder matthew morton
that is like the most commonly asked
question i think i've been asked
but e.t source says the two are not in a
relationship
sophia does not have a boyfriend she's
not going to rush into
anything but matthew's a cool guy and
they hit it off
she's not looking for anything serious
with anyone
nothing with labels she's dating
casually and having fun
but that's it as for sophia and scott
according to e.t source one of the
reasons lionel richie's daughter split
from the 37 year old reality star
was that the relationship was just too
serious for her
at her age i think you just gotta figure
out really what's important to you at
the end of the day
the source adds that she wasn't ready to
be a step mom to his three kids with
kourtney kardashian
ten-year-old mason eight-year-old
penelope and five-year-old reign
it's hard work for all parties i think
for oh you're in court sophia they're
all
really everybody's invested strong like
it's i'm really proud of all of them
when et caught up with scott and khloe
kardashian back in 2019
coco applauded him her sister kourtney
kardashian
and sophia for working together to raise
the kids
i think they're doing amazing and i
think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but
my mom and my dad were like that it took
them years but my dad would come over
once a week for family dinners and would
play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be and
love is love and i'm so proud of them
and i'm so proud of them promoting that
and hopefully
you know inspiring other people that
it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
now et source says that sofia is taking
some time to focus on herself
i feel like for a while i kind of
held back on things because i was afraid
of failure so 2020 is like
no fear i'm gonna be doing acting stuff
really soon
in fact in february sophia told et
that fans of keeping up with the
kardashians shouldn't expect to see her
on the hit reality show
because she's focusing on another big
dream
the roles i'm reading right now are very
like close to
i feel like are kind of similar to me
so they're easy for me to play and i i
really
really enjoy it but i'm very different
from both my sister and my
dad so i feel like i've kind of
navigated
into my lane and it's it's been great
for me